يصف أكثر من 200
جنسية دبي بأنها موطنهم ينجذبون إلى
احتمالات النجاح
وعقلية الأكبر
والأكثر جرأة ،
حاول بجهد أكبر مهما كانت ،
أدرك أنه ربما لا تكون دبي
مجرد مدينة أو
وجهة تستورد المدينة
اسمها أكثر.  نمط الحياة وكذلك
بالنسبة لشخص مختلف تمامًا لديه
قصة مماثلة
[موسيقى
] ، يسعدني مقابلتك ، ومن الجميل أن
ألتقي بك ،
أنا على وشك تناول الغداء مع سيدة
لا تتناول طعامًا
جيدًا إلا إذا كان هناك سبب وجيه
واليوم  هل هي شريحة صغيرة من الجنة ،
كارولين ستانبيري هي ظاهرة إذا لم تكن
موجودة ، فعليك أن
تخترعها ، لذلك دعونا نكون واضحين
أنك لست سيدة
تتناول الغداء ، أنا لا أتناول الغداء أبدًا ولكنك في كل مكان
بشكل جيد  يعني أنني أصبحت أحد
الأولاد ، وأعتقد أنني بدأت ممارسة الأعمال التجارية
هنا ، وأصبحت وجهًا لجميع هذه
الشركات المختلفة
هنا وأعتقد أنه في مثل عمري أصبح الأمر تمامًا
كما تعلم ، فأنا أبلغ من العمر 44 عامًا وأم لثلاثة أطفال
وأن أكون على اللوحات الإعلانية في  الشرق الأوسط
تعرفين شقراء بعيون زرقاء
أنا لست gg حديد ، إنه لأمر مدهش جدًا ، لقد ضغطت على
نفسي وأذهب يا إلهي ،
أنت من المشاهير هنا نعم ربما
هنا رئيسة تنفيذية سابقة كسبت أموالها
رقميًا ثم بدأت شهرتها ببرنامج
الواقع للسيدات
لندن ، لقد استبدلت كل شيء منذ أكثر من أربع سنوات من
أجل حياة في دبي ، يا إلهي ، هذا
مظهر رائع ، لقد وصل عيد الميلاد
بالفعل إلى منزلي ، انظر إلى هذه
بركة الكريسماس
كارولين ستانبيري ودبي صنعت
لبعضهم البعض
يعرفون بالضبط  ماذا
يفعلون ولماذا
أعطتني دبي ريحًا ثانية من
شأنها أن تعيش هكذا
في لوس أنجلوس ، سأكون واحدًا من مليون هنا ، أنا
واحد من شخص
يبدو مثل هذا يأخذ العمل
من هي تلك المرأة على ما
أعتقد أنني بحاجة إلى ذلك  ابدأ
بالتفكير فيما يجب أن أفعله بهذا
التصميم ، سوف أتلقى تغييرًا في دبي
مهما كان ذلك أو أوقفه ،
احتفظ بمسافة بيني
وبين يديك ، لقد
حاولت أنا أحاول ،
هل هذا سيؤذي  أوه ، الجو بارد
لديك تأمين
كيف المخاط  كارولين دبي
مليء بالبهجة والسحر
المغطى مسبقًا ، ربما كان هناك
حدث ساحر ضخم كل ليلة من أيام الأسبوع
لا توجد مزحة ، لذا
نعم الكثير من التألق والسحر ولكن من
الواضح أنه مع السرية ، فإن كل هذه
الأحداث قد
أغلقت نوعًا ما الآن على ما أعتقد  أنت تحب
جميع المقاطع من
السحر بالطبع أعني أنها لحظة أميرة
لكني لا أستمتع بها كل ليلة
من أيام الأسبوع يأتي الناس إلى دبي لإعادة
اختراع أنفسهم
تمامًا كما يفعلون لإعادة ابتكار لوس أنجلوس
الآن ، هناك فكرة أننا  لقد أنجزت
نصف وجهي لم أر
كيف يبدو الأمر ، أود أن أقول ، هل يمكنك رؤية هذا
الشيء مرفوعًا
نعم بالطبع يمكنك بالتأكيد رؤية
الاختلاف الذي شهده هذا الأمر قليلاً
وما زال هذا يتدلى مثل
مهمة ريتشارد القديمة للوسادة  أصبحت
كارولين لهذا اليوم ، هل أنت
مؤثر العبارة المروعة
لا وأكره كلمة أم ، لكنها مشكلة
22 لقد عملت طوال حياتي في
عالم الأعمال ولكن إنستغرام الخاص بي هو
أداة تجعلني على صلة وأنا أفعل
الكثير ر  يمكنك التأثير على الناس فقط ،
لكني أحب جنوني هناك ، لقد
انتهيت من ذلك وأنا أتوجه لتناول العشاء ،
ما هو الشيء المثالي
هو عشاء ساحر ، نعم إنه عشاء ساحر ،
إنه ليلة موعد
أنت لست مدعوًا قصة حياتي
وبرائحة عطر باهظة الثمن
، ذهبت الآن للجزء التالي ،
نعم الشاشات